With my colleague Kurt Konhauser
at University
of Alberta I have been proposing
with working with 13 other members
a program called Light
to Life
which is the evolution of life based
on photosynthesis.
So how did it come to be that an organism
figured out how to use the light from the
sun to make chemical bonds that could feed
you?
That's the essence of what this problem is.
We don't understand the evolution of this
process.
Photosynthesis was a major driver and it was
all microbial in how it came to be.
And so that's what we're trying to do, taking
these molecules and not worrying about the
sequences, looking at the structures and seeing
if we could find the Legos that were the original
Legos and that was added on, and what was
added on after that, and what was added on after.
The problem is very, very inter-disciplinary
so we have physical chemists, we have molecular
biologists, we have geochemists, we have geologists,
structural biologists.
CIFAR allows us to have a very, very broad
group that can interact and potentially then
peel off into smaller groups that can generate
funds for physical research in laboratories
or in the field.
If we had an understanding of how photosynthesis
evolved we could potentially use that to derive
molecules that could split water without biology.
So there's a natural economy based on electrons,
and there's a human economy based on money
and what I want to do is try to couple them
better so that the human economy can be based
upon the natural economy of solar energy splitting
water which is going to be a [INAUDIBLE] problem.
[Music]